diffusée aujourd'hui retrouve sur un
petit chien bear jeu psychologique
apparemment on va nous casser le cerveau
vous avez envie d'avoir le cerveau un
peu cassée moi c'est déjà le cas donc je
m'en bats les steaks ces partis alors
chaque journée est une série de choix le
premier est de commencer la journée
d'accord c'est parti choc on va s'amuser
jones il ya c'est quoi c'est une
histoire de à maintenant si on se met
sous le sommet pied ben voilà parfait ok
c'est marrant comme mécanisme alors
cliquer ici faire le premier pas peut
être plus difficile que le reste d'une
chaîne à droite ya rien on va aller à
gauche on va aller à gauche alors je
pense qu'il va falloir avoir un bon
petit sans orientation quand même oh
c'est un piège c'est un piège duquel je
remonte assez facilement hop là on
tourne souvent dans des choses
auxquelles on ne s'attendait par exemple
se trouve effectivement oh oh oh oh what
à atos très bizarre attend l abondance
dans mon cerveau s'en sort il surchauffe
pas trop ça passe prendre un chemin veut
souvent dire en rater un autre bain
peut-être on repasse la hâte en j'espère
qu'on va pas retourner en arrière un
moment et je vais me perdre comme une
merde ou une oeuvre d'art [ __ ] c'est
bon on peut passer
ouais aulas attend je suis retourné tout
a changé c'est quoi le délire
ok on a réussi à s'en sortir on revient
en arrière jottras de me perdre
la façon dont on perçoit un problème
peut changer à chaque fois qu'on est
confronté à ce problème
oui et ballon par la halle on parle a
sonné dans le musée des bizarreries une
sculpture diabolique c'est passionnant
un prototype d'attraction pour
disneyland effectivement d'accord et
quand tu changes de surface tu vois pas
la même chose dedans at ans à dieu ça
doit être dur à faire un peu comme je
hais ce qui n'a pas une faces d'un cube
dans lequel je peux aller aux allées
[ __ ] génie quand tu en sors ton
environnement tu vas peut-être des
choses que tu n'avais pas vu avant
effectivement bon moment ça va on s'en
sort assez bien je trouve
jusqu'aux membres au plus tard là
j'aurais dû fermer ma gueule va aller
pourra passer par là et je retombe au
point de départ but a au nom est
d'accord je ressors je me retrouve dans
la pièce des tubes on va faire tous les
chemins possibles
on va reprendre là sauf qu il allait à
gauche ou à la droite et on se retrouve
là on va reprendre par la warner va s'en
sortir je sais que vos cerveaux comme en
c1 peut être cassé mais et voilà on est
sorti du cube [ __ ] par la droite par
la droite c'est évident c'est par la
droite repart la droite attend les
diables usé pas quoi le pire labyrinthe
du monde puis repart la droite puis par
la gauche que par la droite vers la
droite puis paladin en fait dès qu'on
voit ça c'est de là d'où on vient donc
c'est pas bon il faut s'en sortir
et là on est baisé voilà là c'est dans
les trois cas regarder si on va là ça
c'est la dombes bien sûr on va là je me
suis perdue à la hâte en démat faire le
chemin en sabre on va reprendre du début
à la fin je pensais depuis sap nous
venons ici je viens du sud et partout
les chemins je reviendrai on va là
ensuite moi je dois suivre le vert oya
qu'est ce qui se passe je n'ai pas
compris tout manger prix mais en tout
cas on est passés mouiller à gauche ni
droite et sarko moins c'est mon nouveau
embrouillés amorce sérieux bien s'il
vous plaît je vais essayer d'aller dans
une phase noir chef le piège c'est ça
non juste si je fais demi-tour savard
changer le chemin mon avis c'est pas
certain mais classé je comprends pas là
haut il ya un dessin certains choix nous
faut tourner en rond oui je suis
d'accord moi j'aimerais bien tourner
plus tôt en quarts et si c'est possible
parce que là ça fait 1 semaine de mai
nulle part on est en rond et or on est
on comment sortir quand tu tournes en
rond tête si je marche en arrière site
marchand amg j'ai beaucoup d'idées de
merde comme ça à proposer si vous voulez
mais par contre je pense voilà à chaque
fois avoir tout mais devant ça à temps
les mecs c'est impossible on gaza abusés
ont fait que tourner en rond qu'on
voulait faire à temps la façon une
solution réfléchissons opposants nous
deux on continue on tourne en rond et je
pense que ça va se débloquer un moment
oh yeah alors aurillac sur ce qui se
dessine au sol une flèche
maintenant la porte s'ouvre bah si
j'aurai la regarde pas et vous voilà
j'avais deviné en laval a le génie
on est en train de casser la roue du
jeune au plus tard quelques pas en
arrière te feront avancer donc là par
exemple je suppose qu'en arrière ça
change totalement le game bat pas du
tout atteint c'est abusé mais qu'à
travers ça on voit qu'à un couloir et
des combats cela abbas et moulié
attendez que je vous expliquer un truc
ça foire tout le temps c'est abuser
c'est le jeu qui humilie les youtuber
arline fait qu'ils allaient à gauche
ou alors je peux suivre ce truc bah moi
je suis la plus légère plus tôt à
s'aventurer dans l'inconnu peut mener à
de belles récompenses
abbas est ce qu'on vient de faire en sur
la flèche voyez olala c'est beau la fin
peut arriver avant qu'on soit prêt
effectivement c'est la fin non la fille
du jour mais non excite la vie ne
consiste pas à se rendre à la fin à ça
continue [ __ ] c'est bon ça j'adore ce
jeu voilà j'adore ça fait travailler un
petit peu le cerveau s'est extrêmement
bien là je suppose qu'ils ont fait ça on
voit un tableau la bac et cacher parfois
on a besoin de voir le monde à travers
la perspective de quelqu'un d'autre
c'est pas faux mais comment passer cette
vitre à écouter j'aime regarder youtube
est le gars qui arrive là c'est pas du
tout comme ça
il ya du verre partout et quand il
regarde là dedans homme s'offre une
nouvelle porte qui vient d'un nouveau-né
endroit je suis fait avoir un choix
qu'on a cassé le jeu je vous promets on
a cassé le jeu auquel j'ai relancé le
jeu
si tu n'as pas aimé où tu as terminé le
jeu essaie de faire autrement
d'accord en fait y'a bien parcours
possible c'est quoi ça aussi c'est
nouveau ça on n'avait pas réussi à faire
ça avant mon gars avant je peux bloquer
la porte en fait ok maintenant à voir se
servir de ça en fait c'est nouveau il ya
plusieurs chemins bosser [ __ ] je t'ai
pas au courant et est-ce que pluton
chemin est court plus tu es un peu con
j'espère pas d'accord je passe ça s'il
vous plaît allez fais pas je me suis
fait une marche à le ok qu'est ce tu vas
faire un nom mais ils ont voulu m'avoir
mais j'avais la solution un moment faut
arrêter de triche à chemin n'est pas bon
ou mauvais il est juste différent
oui enfin bon il ya quand même un et
quand même mauvais ou bon voilà c'est la
réflexion
don't look down vous savez que faut pas
nous dire ne pas faire des choses
passées après les faits ok ok ok ok oui
ce que j'aurais vraiment pas dû faire ça
c'est un truc infinie un assez bon truc
curiosité peut détruire le meilleur de
nouveau très bien le pont se casse le
pouce hors pharma mon dieu je feuilles
rocher à travers un problème ne veut pas
toujours le meilleur résultat
merci fdp ça fait quatre fois de suite
que je trouve là parce que je reçois le
choix n'a pas d'importance si le
résultat est le même
à bondoukou droite ou gauche vas-y
d'oisillons apprendre que le bleu on
veut monter on veut aller vers le haut
et pas vers le bas on va apprendre que
le bleu oh là là comment je vous car
sincèrement je suis un [ __ ] mais du
coup on fait comment
javaux kg ha ben voilà c'est juste de
revenir en arrière ou au pastel là ouais
j'avais plein de couleurs d'un coup ok
échappe
certains choix nous laisse courir autour
de quelque chose sans que ça nous amène
nulle part annoncé la deuxième fin je
suis baiser ben écoutez jean je pense
qu'on a on a assez cassé notre cerveau
actuellement et c'est super sympa [ __ ]
ça joue vachement avec les perspectives
c'est abuser c'est un événement arrive
qu'on le veuille ou non comme t21 non ça
c'est triste un ça c'est triste c'est
faut bien écouter une personne n'a plus
c'est le gars n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo comme d'habitude moi j'aime bien
ce mot faire des petits jeux un petit
peu comme ça qui change un peu du bois
de feu qui ont fait un petit peu
travailler le cerveau n'était pas venu
ça vous a plu pour ce tout très vite
dans une prochaine tout le monde pis